imposing full of history and attention
to detail Wittenberg invites visitors to
take a trip back in time to the
Reformation and experience the vibrant
life of monks beggars merchants
journeyman and prince-electors as
addison as soon as we entered we talked
about how real it seems to pull this off
a temporal sequence with a single
picture so that the history of the
Reformation is depicted what a fantastic
experience the circle surrounding you
you almost think you are in the Middle
Ages to be precise this is the Year 1517
and the birth of the Reformation a 360
degree panorama shows 30 years in the
life of the man who changed the course
of Christianity Martin Luther and this
is where it all began
the door of the castle Church of it
embarked is where the great reformer is
said to have nailed his 95 theses
triggering the conflicts between the
Catholic Church German princes and
scholars this site has a special meaning
for artists yadegar
Assisi Justine is young we are standing
on the very spot about ten years ago I
stood in front of the gate after
visiting friends and suddenly wondered
how a man nailing a few scraps of paper
on the door changed the world
why wasn't I told as a child what
happened here
the palace church is a central motif
annecy sees 360-degree panorama Luther
explains his theses to the people
shaking the Catholic Church to its core
the finishing touches are added to the
panorama picture Assisi and his 15
member team toiled for six years on the
monumental work 30 years of Luther's
life on a canvas 15 metres tall and 75
in circumference
what major theme is the Church's sale of
indulgences which outraged Luther Somoza
gunsa gesellschaft representatives of
every social class stand in line to buy
indulgences the seller of indulgences is
over there looking this way
there you see Luther tearing letters of
indulgences from people's hands and
saying are you mad indulgences aren't
part of the true church they're not
divine the church must not corrupt
itself this way yadegar CC also explored
Luther's role artistically a Jew is
expelled from the city common in that
era Luther who later excoriated the Jews
stands to one side in another scene a
woman is burned as a witch
Luther never said a word against burning
witches at the stake that shows that he
too was a man of his times
I can't reproach him for that he was
only human Assisi and his team staged 30
years from Luther's life and work with
actors and local extras Luther himself
was played by the actor Matthias Pi cat
who was especially fascinated by how
Luke there's character changed at this
one he went through a lot experienced a
lot engaged in many struggles you see it
in his outward appearance but also in
his actions about him orphans in the
projects patron is Margit kessman she's
the ambassador of the Council of the
Evangelical Church in Germany for the
Reformation anniversary I'm enthusiastic
about how the individual scenes are put
together with the appropriate people
that they're speaking with each other
and that a vibrant scene arises and that
it conveys the artists impression of
church history and history as such
this is Jana Garcia's 11 cyclorama he
showed his first in 2003 it was a huge
panorama of Mount Everest others larger
and more spectacular followed like the
nature panorama titled Amazonia pura
Cyclorama of Pergamon Assisi travelled
to Turkey and recreated a day in 129 AD
since 2012 his Berlin Wall picture has
shown people the border between East and
West Berlin on a gray November day in
the early 1980s
now visitors can immerse themselves in
the world of the Reformation in Vinton
bag the Rotunda will remain open for
five years meanwhile Yannick RCC is
already working on new panoramas